- Go, Garfield.
Just go.
Go. Go.
[chuckles]
- Yes.
Well, what do I
want today?
- Whatever you need,
ask Duane Reade.
- Well, I would love a box
of toothache powder.
Mm-hmm.
- Best I got.
- Yes, and some of the, um,
stop being gay pills.
No, I'm stocked up on those.
Just, um, some toilet tissues.
Don't mind if I do.
[chuckles]
For doo-doo.
- [giggles]
Where is my con-dahm?
- I know.
I'm a failure.
I couldn't do it.
- Ugh.
I'll do it myself.
- Yes?
- Hi.
I'd like to purchase
a con-dahm.
- [grunts]
Yes. Shh. Shh.
Cops could hear you.
Are you crazy?
- Crazy horny.
[chuckles]
- Uh, we don't sell
rubber skins here,
certainly not to a woman,
of all people.
- [gasps]
Well, then, how am I supposed
to have sex for pleasure?
- Why don't you ask
the other gals
on the corner of Unwed Road
and Whore Boulevard?
- I'm a whore
because I want to have sex?
Don't you want to have sex?
- Of course
I want to have sex.
I love sex.
It feels so good on my penis.
So unless you'd like
to go around back
and get bent over a pallet
of Gold Medal flour
or get arrested,
I suggest you leave.
- Bent over?
I don't even like
that position.
I'm more of a "lay there
and take it" kind of gal.
- Oh.